hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2016 british biographical
drama movie called a street cat named
bob
this movie is based on a true story the
movie begins with a homeless man named
james who currently works as a street
busker however no one cares about his
performance and not even a single
pedestrian gives him money for the
tuneless song he sings
at some point he sometimes searches for
food from the trash bin ain't leftovers
given to him as he has no money left
turns out that james is a former heroin
addict when one of his addict friends
baz is looking for a nearby drug dealer
james ignores him and keeps walking to a
restaurant where he orders a three
pounds food for dinner but he doesn't
have enough money to pay for the meal he
offers to sing a song but gets expelled
by the waiter as he throws the food in a
sink full of water after that he meets
baz again who is sitting inside an
unlocked car and offers james drugs
desperated he eventually takes the drugs
and gets high
the next day everyone including the
rightful car owner is shocked when they
see james laying unconscious because of
odd
long story short he recovers and is
discharged from the hospital he
immediately meets val a rehabilitation
consultant who warns him about his
current condition and offers to help him
she prescribes him methadone and
requires him to visit her every two
weeks
after that he continues his boring life
as a homeless and nomad man
meanwhile fal manages to get him into
council housing after convincing the
lady that james is persistent to become
clean from drugs and the only way to
support it is by getting off the street
for a while
not long after he is very happy after
knowing that he doesn't need to live on
the street again but he has to comply
with val's term to stay on the
rehabilitation program and won't miss a
single meeting with her that night while
enjoying his me time he hears a strange
noise outside the bathroom
james panics but turns out that it is a
cute ginger cat looking for food
he feels connected with the cat and
offers him some milk
after that the cat refuses to go out and
chooses to stay with james the next day
james attempts to find the owner of the
cat but it seems like the cat belongs to
no one so he just lets him go he then
continues busking on the street when he
accidentally meets his father it is
revealed that james has been estranged
from his family for years
his dad has married to another woman
hillary who doesn't like the presence of
james she doesn't even allow james to
come to their house during christmas
left with no option the dad gives his
son some money and walks away he then
returns home and finds the cat has been
waiting for him outside his room this
time with a purulent wound on his body
he calls his neighbor betty who is an
animal lover and suggests james go to a
local charity vet to treat the wound
she loves the cat and decides to name
him bob despite her being allergic to
cats
he immediately brings bob to the vet
where they have to wait for a very long
time and then the cat is uncomfortable
there since bob is unfamiliar with the
situation and is afraid of dogs
long story short bob is treated and
james has to pay 22 pounds for the
medicine with all the money given by his
dad earlier as expected ginger cats are
naughty and bob refuses to consume the
medicine but somehow he obeys betty and
finally is willing to consume it
afterward betty shares that she is 100
and a drug and hates drug addicts
james is aware of this and lies to her
about his current condition
the following day he comes to val who is
very disappointed as james missed the
appointment yesterday due to bringing
bob to the vet
he tells her about betty and his
feelings toward her but val prohibits
james from getting into a relationship
since his current unstable emotional
condition
at some point james feels bored and
tempted to buy drugs again but luckily
he is bob who accompanies him all the
time
bob is then castrated and is given a
shield to prevent him from licking the
stitches
he is uncomfortable with it and begs
james to take it off which he does
the next day james sets bob free before
going to work
however the cat keeps following him even
sneaking into the bus that he takes
left with no option james uses his
shoelace as a leash and eventually
brings bob with him
surprisingly bob attracts the crowd who
asked to take a picture with him also
thanks to bob now everyone loves
watching james performing songs and a
lot of pedestrians give him money james
is very happy since he has never
collected such an amount of money while
being a busker a few moments later an
old lady approaches them and adores bob
so much since her ginger cat has passed
away
since then james has the opportunity to
enjoy a decent life and decides to keep
bob he even buys bob a proper cat
harness the next day bash shows up
begging for money
feeling pity for him james gives him
several bucks and immediately walks away
james brings bob again while busking and
he attracts more pedestrians meaning
that he collects more money than before
suddenly the same old lady appears and
gives bob new cat food and scarf as
christmas gifts that evening he
coincidentally meets betty who invites
him to dinner at her room there james
asked betty about her life but she keeps
avoiding the topic
now james is capable of buying bob more
proper cat food
that evening he accidentally finds baz
who is lying unconscious on the ground
because of overdosed he immediately
calls an ambulance but unfortunately baz
later dies in the hospital
later betty reveals that the room is his
brother's place who also died because of
overdosing after hearing betty's story
and bazz's death james is more dedicated
to get clean from drugs but val states
that he has to take it slowly that's why
he has to keep consuming methadone but
in a lower dose
it's christmas and james and betty start
to become romantically attached they
decorate the room and celebrate
christmas together with bob betty
presents james with a very beautiful
painting which is her deceased brother's
work
after that they go on a date and james
shares to betty about his intention to
visit her dad on new year's eve
long story short the day has come and
james comes to his father's house
turns out that the father now also has
daughters free in faith he also brings
bob with him who eventually creates
chaos at the house destroying a vase and
a christmas tree the cat also triggers a
fight between james father and his new
wife
the following day while busking a dog
randomly takes a piss on james guitar
case which triggers an argument between
james and the dog owner everything
becomes chaos and james gets arrested
because of creating a mess
although proven innocent james is banned
from busking for six months
val immediately orders him to go to a
drug store to get his methadone
unfortunately for james while consuming
the medicine betty spots him and is very
upset as james has lied to her about his
condition
desperate as he currently has no source
of income he visits the big issue office
and applies for the paper sales job
the woman reminds him to sell the paper
only in his own territory james agrees
with the term and start selling the
papers in his territory as expected bob
manages to draw the crowd to buy the
paper while they get the opportunity to
take a picture with a cat
one of the crowd even proposes to write
a story about him in the cat
long story short suddenly a couple
approaches james and bob in another
paper seller's territory and demands to
buy the paper after taking photos with
the cat the envious seller accuses james
for poaching even though he doesn't
because of that james is prohibited from
selling the paper for one month
james tries to reconcile with betty but
she refuses to talk with him
long story short james is short of cash
but he chooses to buy food for the cat
rather to fulfill his hunger at some
point since he is jobless now james
really runs out of money and has to pick
out food from the trash bin again
the next day he illegally begins busking
again but in other places until betty
finds him and warns him to comply with
the prohibition or he will get arrested
both of them then get into an argument
and betty wants to end their
relationship
one month has passed and now james is
allowed to sell papers again
while marketing the papers a rude woman
approaches them and attempts to buy bob
james politely rejects the offer but the
mother keeps begging until he gets fed
up bob suddenly runs away and james
tries to chase after him but loses him
afterward bob doesn't return for two
days which makes james devastated on the
other side a lady who appears at the
beginning of the movie learns that bob
and james become viral on an online
video sharing platform and comes up with
an idea to write a book about them
back to james losing bob almost makes
him want to get back to becoming a drug
addict but somehow bob suddenly returns
to the house and he withdraws the
intention
the following day james visits val
telling her that he is ready to come off
the methadone
he then apologizes to betty who
eventually forgives him and supports him
for the upcoming process
indeed the journey is not easy
he suffers grueling and torturing
withdrawal symptoms but after a week the
symptoms are all gone and james is now
officially cleaned from drugs
he visits betty only to find out that
she is moving out of the housing as she
wants to start a new chapter of her life
she reveals her real name and gives
james her new address hoping that he
will visit her someday after that james
meets the lady in her team discussing
the book she wanted to write he also
reconciles with his dad who reveals that
he kept distance from james because he
was ashamed of failing to become a good
father
at the end of the movie everyone
including betty his father and val are
celebrating james book launch where he
expresses his gratitude towards everyone
who has been supporting him
since then james and bob start a new
page of their life together
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching